welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and this is our breakdown of
Netflix's The Witcher season three next
time we see geralt we'll be saying hello
falca and goodbye Henry Cavill but knock
knock who's there it's the other
Hemsworth also behind door number two
joining us on this breakdown the ringers
Jessica Clements joining us to co-host
this breakdown hi I love The Witcher and
I miss doing The Witcher breakdowns from
new Rockstar so much that I've come back
to do a third at one you can't stay away
from this The Witcher unlike everybody
else has me in a choke hold uh and I
will say that I will say that openly I
love it and I'm gonna keep talking about
it forever now just an honor The Witcher
we will be singing this whole breakdown
in the tune of The Bard song for The
Witcher The Ballad oh just kidding we're
not gonna do that to you we wouldn't do
that too ever this uh season The Witcher
was Heavy folks there's a ton of new
information every character from season
two makes a return appearance and we
dive into the importance of staying
neutral while season two focused on the
witcher's history and Karen mourn the
third season focused on the Northern
Realms their Mages and their
matriarchies they also delivered their
own form of Ocean's 11 movie in episode
5 art of Illusion which is super weird
so it was such a weird stunt why would
you do that but it was so fun it was
just an Ocean's 11 movie and I was like
hey I love a heist and I love these
flashbacks so let's do them both
together it's been 18 months since
Witcher season two and we've been
waiting for more information in regards
to the wild Hunt Emir and how many
people want Siri and for what personal
gain let's quit lollygagging let's break
down this season okay we start seeing a
very close family-like relationship
between Jennifer and geralt in series of
the first part of the season in an
interview with the showrunner they
mentioned that Jennifer would be
grappling with motherhood while training
Siri and girls wants to start a new
family we're anticipating this but after
leading season two everyone's walls are
justifiably uh reminder Jennifer
betrayed Siri to get her powers back
from bullith Mir which slept girls
heartbroken after being betrayed by the
woman he loved and no one could really
trust Jennifer after the damage
volathmir caused everyone has different
motivations but it's clear Jennifer and
geralt are to keep Siri alive and safe
so they rekindle their love and rebuild
their lost trust over the first five
episodes of the season and build a
messed up family while Jennifer and
geralt may have genuine motivations
everyone else just feels unbalanced we
focused on six major groups Emperor Emir
of nifguard Rios and his mystery boss
the elves the Brotherhood of Mages the
wild Hunt and everyone's favorite
redania we hate radon
I hate radanya started with nilfgaard it
is the most powerful Nation on the
continent that's why everyone's trying
to take them on in war because if
nilfgaard chooses they could wipe
everyone out their Emperor's Emperor
Amir AKA The White Flame who everyone
thought was dead and popped up as the
big reveal at the end of season two his
known motivation in the series is to
capture Siri and have her by his side to
rule nilfgaard because Siri is very
important in Politics As She's the
rightful heir to Sentra he can
legitimately claim Citrus Throne instead
of just conquering it it's revealed that
Amir was working with legal forts the
Mage who was dating tessia blending love
in the Brotherhood politics was not
really ever a good idea but unless you
read time of contempt you had no idea it
was viegel Fords who was the boss made
using reins to capture Siri in episode 5
the art of the illusion the Ocean's 11
episode viegelford spoke with garal
about how he can't Define himself and as
an orphan he was mistreated by everyone
but especially by a man just like me so
he turned the sorcery out of spite which
sounds a lot it stopped
I'm so happy that we now have a
teleprompter up here and a model down
here so I can't see when you're laughing
at me so he turned the sorcery out of
spite which sounds a lot like Chief Sage
Baylor the magical advisor in blood
origin due to his status a lot of people
didn't take him seriously so that anger
mistreatment and paranoia festered
eventually guiding him to chaos magic
and staging a coup then leading to the
conjunction of the spears like falca and
Siri history is doomed to repeat itself
and we see that both in vehicle Forts
and Baylor whose anger stems from
mistreatment and wanting unruly power
condemning man and bringing themselves
higher I agree with it and disagree with
it we don't know what vehicle fort's
ultimate goal is but he mentions wanting
to Mentor Siri after the coup as of now
we know Amir wants Syria for political
schemes and Vigo forts for power so he
delivered a fake Siri to emmer so they
both get what they want it's unclear if
Emma knows that that's a fake Siri but
spoilers from the book he immediately
figures it out okay
now episode six was incredibly
significant in my opinion because it
showed everyone had preconceived agendas
with the conclave and some unknowingly
aligned with others but ultimately this
ended with the fall of the aratuza that
was meant to bring Mages together
Jennifer tessia stregabore and Vigo were
in support of this with no ulterior
motives is Street and tris loyal to the
Brotherhood wanted to keep the book of
monolith safe Philippa kirametz and
glevacig were all in support of
rodania's coup but wanted to expose the
traitor among the Mages but would end in
the fall of the Brotherhood and taking
Siri the Squirtle nilfgaard Lydia and
vehicle forts were clearly the enemy
offering the elves eratusa as
compensation as it used to be theirs in
bikaforts and Amir just wanting Siri
geralt and Jennifer knew there was a
mole working for nilfgaard at first
we're led to believe it's Strega bore
but deeksha and Philip had an inkling of
his vehicle ports and had to make
certain by holding the Mages hostage and
facilitating an attack on aratuza the
plan was to send rodanya soldiers and
capture the traitorous Mages while
Prince radovid would take Syrian
eventually marry her into the royal
family Unfortunately The Messengers sent
to alert rodania to bring soldiers was
intercepted and killed by the scores
Hill who we knew were working with
nilfgaard and was able to launch a
surprise attack on aratuza back in
Virginia after ditra and Philippa fail
at aratuza King vismir orders Dykstra to
kill Philippa to set an example because
someone must pay for their failures
instead deeksha offers to kill himself
and their weird friendship couldn't be
stronger tilpa moved by dijkstra's
willingness to kill himself inspired her
plan to assassinate King vismir and
raise his younger Prince brother radovid
to the throne as the new king of rodania
it's clear this is all a surprise to
dextra and looks like the relationship
might be questioned in season four if
you're done watching The Witcher but you
still need something to scratch that
Slavic folklore itch then you should
check out gourd created by a team that
includes former frostpunk and The
Witcher 3 developers Gord is a single
player Dark Fantasy strategy game where
to survive you must build but to Prevail
you must conquer the darkness beyond the
gates lead the people of the tribe of
the Dawn as they Venture deep into the
Forbidden lands complete
life-threatening quests in this dark
fantasy world while managing a populist
whose personal stories and well-being
can decide the fate of your tribe Gord
is coming August 17th on PC PlayStation
5 and Xbox series XS to pre-order a copy
for yourself click the link in the
description below now as for the
remaining Mages that made it out it's
clear that after Tessie has sudden
suicide that yennefer will be the new
face of power amongst the rest in the
books there's a team of Mages named The
Lodge of sorceresses founded by Philippa
after the ruins of then it Island the
organization was built and sort of free
of any political affiliations though
Philippa has her own agenda in radanya
this group's first plan is to eliminate
vehicle Forts and formulate how to move
forward istrid being one if not only the
remaining male Mage tried to save the
book of monoliths and yet guided vehicle
forts to it then was pushed through a
portal created by vivoforts the book of
monolith is very important because it's
the key to understanding the monoliths
not only do they hold great magic they
can also be linked to the different
monsters inhabiting their realm we don't
know where Vigil Ford sent istrid but
can't expect him back in season four
while episode 6 is probably the most
significant episode 7 is definitely my
favorite for many reasons this episode
focuses mainly on Siri as you finds
herself dehydrated with intense visions
and confronting her subconscious all
while lost in the korath desert The
Witcher spends a lot of time traveling
to different towns and Villages but not
different regions and I like that we
explore far south of the northern
Kingdoms in this episode in this journey
we're introduced to the hero quacks the
Unicorn AKA little horse from the book
story line they Kindle a very close
friendship like we see in most of the
episode These unicorns are also super
magical with powers that travel through
space and time and spheres we also get
Siri singing a little sacrifice this is
the name of the fourth short story and
the sword of Destiny which tells the
tale of garal and yaskir AKA dandelion
helping a human realize he is in love
with a mermaid while she's hallucinating
she gets an array of Visions one of her
mother and grandmother who blame her for
everything happening and I would too the
one Vision that she gets and continues
throughout the episode though that is
very very important is the legendary
falca a princess with Elven blood who
was burned at the stake a century ago
balka led a rebellion against her father
the king of rodania and killed him his
wife and her two half-brothers volca is
also a distant relative to Siri based on
the Netflix Witcher page in these Vision
Syrian faulker are talking a Tavern the
same Tavern series tied up in at the end
of the season Falco will encourage Siri
to use her powers even Fire magic to
save the unicorn's life and turn to
destruction Falco reveals to her how she
will have to kill others even the people
that she loves and it's just the way
literally like Star Wars which
rightfully scares Siri leading her to
relinquish her powers now it's unclear
if Syria has lost her powers totally but
in the witcher's books spoiler three two
one she completely gave up her abilities
she now goes by the name Falco which the
actress Freya Allen commended saying I
think it's just part of her shredding
Siri because she's killed someone so
it's kind of an element of this is what
I am I've done that and I can't take
that back I'm no different to falca I
think that's the idea Siri is now part
of the rats a band of Misfits that get
in all kinds of trouble just like me and
Eric just like
we're little rats they do call us that
that's what people call us well this is
a band of Misfits that get in all kinds
of trouble a different life to what
series used to in the books they're
pretty pretty bad uh with two of them
sexually assaulting Siri which will
probably not play out in this series but
from their small introduction we see
they're skewed morally they're also
getting their own spin-off show that
plays as a prequel series before they
met Siri while she might not have her
powers right now I don't think all will
be lost Siri will probably gain her
abilities again in season four and after
a pretty underwhelming fight with
beagleforts geralt gets his ass kicked
he has a broken back and leg Tris
recovers his body from the water then
he's taken to the broccolin forest that
we've seen before in the first season
and at the beginning of this one yaskir
attracts him back to the forest and
stands by as he reluctantly recovers the
damage vehicle Fords did was intense and
the healing methods that the dryads have
just don't really work on witchers with
patience Jennifer's magic in a geralt
version Elixir he heads out with yaskir
and milva the Elven Archer from the
broccolin forest to save Siri who they
believe is captured by nilfgaard they
don't know that's not the real Siri yet
so season four will be a rude awakening
for this Trio we don't know if he's
fully healed Jennifer says there are
some wounds magic can't heal but we see
him take out a bunch of nilfguardian
soldiers later but one little swipe to
the back could cost him his life hero no
longer is neutral like he stated
throughout the season he will kill
anyone and do anything to save his
family family oh my God it's Ocean's 11
and freaking Fast and Furious I think
Ocean's 11 and fast furious are like
Multiverse variants of each other no 100
they're variant versions of each other
but what about the elves Amir has these
elves wrapped around his finger he
killed Francesca's baby to avoid a
divide in the to avoid a divide in the
elves he killed the one about to uprise
he got most of the elves killed in every
battle and it doesn't stop there he's
using them for their geographical sense
and as throwaway Pawns in his army so
Francesca and frangelo reunite and fight
for nilfgaard during the coup and let me
tell you a lot of elves die fringella
suggests that Amir send them both to
centria to keep the supply chain open
and give the elves their own place to
stay to which Amir says yes but not to
all the elves wanting to keep the scoia
tail to himself as they know the land
better than anyone else Francesca
decides to go with amir's negotiation
and forget about Siri until fragila
who's against the idea admit Samir was
behind the murder of Francesca's baby in
season two Francesca had no idea but
also felt completely betrayed that
fringella never told her remember
Francesca's baby was the answer to the
elves who couldn't procreate instead of
fighting a long MILF guard she decides
the elves needed to rebuild and grow
strong using her baby as a shiny beak in
A New Hope by the end of their argument
Francesca swears to make the two suffer
kahir and frangelis seemed so lost this
season and they should be brinjilla has
been sentenced to be a wine taster until
she dies and upon escaping swears to
make a mere pay kahir has a change of
heart maybe after slaying his friend or
being confronted by fringilla and offers
his life to Siri who can't do it to
allow geralt in Siri time to escape the
scoia tale he holds them back and that's
a lash shot we have we don't know if
he's dead but we know frangila is alive
it has a new enemy a new enemy why do
you say baby like that okay the season
showed everyone after Siri but the wild
Hunt the finale of the second season
focused a lot on the wild Hunt and their
desire for Siri in this season we only
have a single episode with the group as
they chase Syria in the forest and leave
a piece of their armor behind so far The
Witcher seasons have been based on the
novels from sapkowski this season
adapted from time of contempt which uses
the wild Hunt as a rumor season 4 is
supposed to be an adaptation of baptism
of fire we probably just can't expect
the wild Hunt to show up until like
season five or six if it's going off the
books unfortunately like a lot of
production season 4 of The Witcher will
probably be delayed as a warning I'll be
revealing some story arcs from baptism
of fire to piece some stuff together but
here's what we can expect in season four
our new anticipated girl being played by
Liam Hemsworth in an interview with
Yahoo news the producer tomek Ron The
Witcher mentioned we have a very very
good plan to introduce our new girl and
our new vision of geralt with Liam he
continues it's very lore accurate it's
very close to what was set out in the
books and I think this change will be
quite Flawless but at the same time it
will be a new girl it will be a new face
for this character and I think it will
also be very very exciting to see no
hate at all no hate at all I'm just like
a little confused right there's a couple
possibilities they could be getting into
series World jumping abilities if
there's another world with goral it
could be Liam Hemsworth CNS tomek came
from blood origin where they had sinachi
as the narrator maybe this retelling and
is a different narrator with a slightly
different POV the injuries he sustained
from Vigo forts had different side
effects or the makeshift Elixir he made
could have shape-shifting properties the
theories are endless from the books I
just don't know what from the books is
more accurate enough to justify changing
the character and aligns with where we
are in the story and baptism of fire
kahir joins goral in his journey to
nilfgaard though at first completely
against it milva allows him to join so
those are things that we could probably
expect in season four yeah uh all very
interesting thoughts Jessica it was so
amazing to break down this season of
Witcher with you uh it's always great
it's always great to see you in the chat
with you and nerd out with you and for
all of you watching thank you thank you
so much uh please subscribe to all three
channels in the new rockstars Network
and check out all the amazing geeking
out Jessica is doing over on the ringer
Network you can follow me on all social
platforms at eavos follow Jessica at
Lulu underscore Clemons thanks for
watching and we'll see you next time bye
everybody uh toss a coin
[Music]
thank you